je commence à voir les dessins de temps
la douleur était persistante est quand
même assez douloureux je me disais ça se
peut pas c'est impossible que ça soit
101 et richard souffre d'arythmie a fait
quatre infarctus en moins dix ans mais
comme beaucoup de femmes elle a
longtemps refusé de reconnaître son
problème
chamfort jeu rationalise est toujours
mes symptômes
malgré le fait que je teste au goût du
jour gardées puisqu'ils venaient comme
réponse peut-être d'un infarctus
infarctus angine infarctus
cette attitude est très fréquente
constate le docteur george annas
populairement ont pas ce que c'est les
hommes qui meurent du coeur les femmes
meurent du cancer du sein mais les
femmes sont cinq fois plus apte à mourir
de problèmes cardiaques le cancer du
sein
de plus une femme qui a fait une crise
cardiaque est plus susceptible qu'un
homme doit mourir ou d'en refaire une
autre dans les six mois qui suivent
et dans notre unité de soins intensifs
cardiaque actuellement il ya plus de
femmes que d'hommes
donc ça témoigne du fait que les femmes
sont à risque il faut sensibiliser les
femmes mais également le personnel
médical pensent annie richard qui a dû
insister pour être hospitalisée quelques
heures seulement avant de faire son
troisième infarctus
le diagnostic de l'urgentologue une
bronchite
j'ai l'impression que la discrimination
face aux fermes parce que j'avais été un
homme stockton qu'on m'aurait pas fait
attendre
ous longtemps à l'urgence autre
statistique inquiétante quatre fois sur
cinq on est incapable de reconnaître les
signes qui annoncent une crise cardiaque
chez la femme avec tous les dangers que
cela comporte
le camp c'est une crise cardiaque et on
ouvre l'artère rapidement on réduit le
dommage permanent du muscle cardiaque et
on améliore le pronostic à lancer les
femmes ne se présentent pas ou se
présente tardivement elle manquait
l'opportunité qu'on puisse les aider
une bonne nouvelle depuis quelques
années on recrute de plus en plus de
femmes pour les essais cliniques sur les
maladies cardiaques et les médicaments
pour les soigner ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal